You can have a seat.
Church, good morning again, it is great
to see you this morning.
My name is John. I'm, uh, the lead teaching pastor here,
which means I preach most of the time,
but I am not preaching today
because we have a special guest with us, uh,
a man who's made a, a huge impact on my life over the years
and I'm super thankful to have him here with us today.
This is Dr. Richard Ross. Don't you come ahead for this way.
Um, so when Emily
and I moved to Fort Worth for seminary, I had known
of Dr. Ross before
and found out where he was going to church
and said, that's where we're going to church.
That's all I knew. And it was because of his heart
and love for Jesus.
And you'll hear that today
and impacting me in such ways that has marked me from
that time forward for a deep love, for just
how great our God is
and to give everything to him in response.
You'll hear that and see that
and uh, so he will share about his
experience with the Lord as well.
But I wanna pray for him before we get going.
Lord, thank you so much for this man who's, who's meant
so much to so many who's spent
decades teaching in the seminary.
But, but Lord, I know his heart is to declare your glory
and the supremacy of Jesus over everything.
So Lord, fill him with your spirit now.
Fill us with your spirit to hear what you want us
to hear today and be impacted
and challenged in the ways you want us to be changed today.
That we can't walk away from this
just the same way we walked in, uh,
that you would meet us in that time of need that we all have
for your glory, for our good.
Speak through him today. In Jesus' name, amen.
For us to have sweeping revival in the United States.
God can do that any way he wants to,
but wouldn't it be wonderful if by the multiplication
of pastors like Pastor John who have a heart for Jesus?
What if they were filling pulpits all across the land?
It would be a wonderful thing, thrilled to be here
where this precious man of God is ministering.
But there's actually a personal reason why I'm really
glad to be here today.
Uh, only if I get an official speaking invitation,
do I get a pass to leave the Happy Hills nursing home?
You guys are my excuse this morning.
I got to have a breakfast taco instead of that little bottle
of insurer, which is what they usually give me.
Nobody will be checking my diapers today. This is all good.
In fact, I'm gonna have to be a little bit honest with you.
I, I have been a lifetime youth leader
and even at my age, I know it's ridiculous,
but it, even at my age, I'm still speaking
to teenagers, I can't believe it.
Uh, but just a while back my age
actually became an emotional issue to me.
I was gonna speak for a citywide disciple now a lot
of youth pastors, a lot of youth groups, and I knew the band
and the band was gonna be hip and cool
and I thought, okay, the teenagers are rocking with the band
and then I walk out.
Now that's gonna be ridiculous.
So the day before disciple that weekend, I went
to Hulen Mall near my house,
I bought my first pair of skinny jeans.
I thought, okay, I can't change my face,
but if I could walk on platform
and skinny jeans, maybe it won't be quite so bad.
Well, they did give me a green room to get ready
and things did not go well.
Have you ever tried to pull skinny jeans over adult diapers?
You ever tried to do that? I had
to leave the skinny jeans behind
and wear my middle aged dockers.
It was so sad, but at least the young people knew the sermon
will be brief.
Anyway, I feel an instant closeness with you
because I happen to know a whole bunch
of you were sitting in the audience at Falls Creek when I
was preaching, but actually that would just apply to those
of you that are 50 or older.
So we won't talk about the rest of you. Uh, true statement.
I have been through, I have experienced two
spiritual awakenings in my life
and I wanna tell you about them.
The first spiritual awakening occurred when I was 19.
It was part of the Jesus movement. Do you know that term?
The Jesus movement.
Uh, in the late 1960s, about half a million,
mainly college students just dropped out of society,
left school and many of them moved into communes.
Communes were places of LSD, free love, artistic expression.
We call them either hippies,
we call them the flower children.
Those people were just about as lost
as any human being can be,
but a supernatural Jesus just by his own designs.
In a short period of time, late 1969,
early 1970, began to win hundreds
of thousands of those hippies to Jesus
and they became hardcore followers of his.
Maybe you saw the movie Jesus Revolution.
I know you would remember those multitudes
of young people out in the Pacific Ocean being baptized.
It was so exciting.
By the way, I actually appeared in that movie.
If you want to touch me
after the service that can be arranged Most
of revolution, you know, they had to recreate most of that,
but they used some actual footage from the revival.
There was one shot of a quarter of a million
of us at a huge Jesus festival.
One of those pixels is me.
I'm not really sure which pixel that is, but that's me.
And I want you to know that I was in the movie.
The second spiritual awakening
that I had was not a broad awakening like
the Jesus movement.
The Second Awakening took place 36 years later
and it was personal to me.
I heard about a man in New Jersey
that was talking about Jesus in a way
that I was not familiar with and, and I was intrigued
and I thought, I've gotta hear more about
what this man has to say.
So I wrote him, I said, Hey, I'm nobody.
You don't know me and you're really busy,
but if I come up to New Jersey, you have to eat lunch.
Could I just sit with you while you eat lunch
and you talk to me about Jesus?
And he wrote me back and he said, I don't know you
and I am really busy,
but I would welcome sharing a lunch with you.
So I went. He began to talk with me about Jesus,
but in a specific way.
He really put a focus on via the ascension of Jesus
from the Mount of Olives.
40 days after the empty tomb
and that passage of scripture, the truthfulness of
that scripture began to rock my world.
We really looked carefully at Psalm one 10.
Let me just read the verses that were so important to me.
King David was given supernatural ability
to look a thousand years into the future to see an event
that would actually take place.
And this is what David saw looking forward.
The Lord says to my Lord, sit at my right hand
until I make your enemies a footstool for your feet.
The Lord will extend your mighty scepter from Zion.
You will rule in the midst of your enemies.
I thought, oh my goodness, Jesus ascended.
I did know about that. But then as he went
through the clouds, he returned to heaven
and as he returned to heaven,
he approached his father in heaven
and the Bible says his father said, son,
be enthroned at my right hand.
I will make your enemies a footstool for your feet.
I will put the scepter of all authority in your your hand.
From that moment until this morning,
Jesus has been reigning king of kings and Lord of lords.
Not only is he my sacrifice, not only is he my savior, he
is my monarch.
He is my king.
Henderson Hills believes in the second coming, all of you do
the way things are going in the world.
It might be sooner rather than later,
but what if you're alive at the second coming?
What if you go out in your front yard
because of the trumpet music and you look up
and you literally see Jesus split open the heavens
and you see him descend to earth in that moment?
What do you think in that moment as he is descending
to earth, do you think he will be great and glorious?
I know you do watch who Jesus is
in his second coming is precisely who I was talking
to in my living room at four o'clock this morning.
That is who he is.
I'm not trying to be facetious,
but it is almost as if on the day of the second coming,
Jesus just stands up from the throne steps over here
and drops to earth.
What I'm trying to say is that is who he is.
I just wonder, I'm asking you individually,
is it possible that you're kind of where I was
in 2006, you've been redeemed,
you've even been transformed somewhat,
but do you need to experience a Christ awakening
to help you know, would you allow me
to ask you some personal questions?
When you prayed this morning,
I'm talking about at home this morning.
Did you have any sense in your prayers this morning?
I am approaching the king of glory.
Any sense of that at all?
Did anything in your voice sound like I am speaking
to royalty?
You know your prayer this morning?
Would you say you spent more time
declaring his glory
and greatness than you spent asking for things?
Here's a powerful question.
Are their members of your family
or your close friends who've been smitten with the greatness
of Christ because of spending time with you?
I'm gonna repeat that. Are there members of your family
or your close friends who've been smitten with the greatness
of Christ because of spending time with you?
Are you contagious? So I ask you again,
do you need a Christ awakening?
And of course that question raises another question.
What exactly is a Christ awakening?
I'll give you a definition.
A Christ awakening occurs when God's spirit
uses God's word to wake up a believer
to the full extent of the supremacy of Christ.
Three themes. First, you are awakened
to his enthroned glory.
Second, you begin to adore him more deeply.
Third, you arise
to join him in bringing his kingdom on earth.
We need to explore each of those three themes.
First, you are awakened
to his enthroned glory.
Henderson Hills does things by the book.
I'm not talking about an operations manual.
I'm talking about the book the Bible to discover
what the enthroned glory of Christ consists of.
We go to scripture and that's exactly what I'm about to do.
I sat down and went from Genesis to Revelation
and found the following scriptures
that present the glory of God the Son.
Everything I'm about to say is scripture.
I want you to take every phrase of scripture
and let this sink into your heart.
He Jesus is
before all things by him Jesus,
all things were created in heaven and on earth in Him.
Jesus, all things hold together.
He Jesus is the image of the invisible God
and the radiance of God's glory.
He Jesus is the exact expression
of God's nature in Him.
All the fullness of God is pleased to dwell.
God has highly exalted him Jesus
and bestowed on him the name that is above every name.
He Jesus is enthroned at the right hand
of the majesty on high.
His throne is forever and ever.
The Father has bestowed splendor and majesty on him. Jesus.
He is wonderful counselor. He is prince of peace.
His dominion is an everlasting dominion
that will not pass away.
His kingdom will not be destroyed.
His greatness reaches to the end of the earth.
He Jesus is the head of the body, the church,
he Jesus is preeminent all authority in heaven
and on earth has been given to him.
Jesus as the lamb who was slain.
He is worthy to receive power and wealth and wisdom
and strength and honor and glory and praise.
He Jesus is the way, the truth and the life.
He Jesus is the alpha and the Omega, the first
and the last, the beginning and the end.
And this morning a multitude sings to him
who sits on the throne and to the lamb be praised and honor
and glory in power forever and ever.
Henderson heals. That is who my Jesus is.
I'm asking you the personal question.
Do you need to be more awakened to that Jesus
first you are awakened to his enthroned glory,
but second, you deeply adore him.
You can remember your prayers from this morning.
Do you remember any part of your prayer this morning
that sounded like adoration?
Not thanking him,
but telling him you literally adore him?
Now, some of you may think this is a little simplistic,
and I apologize if you do,
but I do my morning worship in our living room.
Nobody else is awake.
So I have a lot of freedom to just kind of do my thing.
I think I very much like sitting on one side
of the room and picturing on the opposite side of the room
an elevated throne.
Sometimes I walk over to it when I walk over
to the elevated throne,
the footstool is about even with my eyes.
I like standing before that elevated throne
because I never wanna forget the regal glory of who he is
and it causes my heart to adore him more.
Now, you don't have to use your imagination like that,
but I wanna ask you, does any part
of your mourning prayer sound like adoration?
Let me just give you an earthly example
of what I'm talking about.
You might remember the story of King David
and his three mighty men.
Let me read to you from second Samuel 23.
David was then in the stronghold
and the garrison of the Philistines was then at Bethlehem.
David said, longingly, oh, that someone would give me water
to drink from the well of Bethlehem.
That is by the gate.
Then the three mighty men broke through the camp
of the Philistines
and drew water out of the well of Bethlehem that was
by the gate and carried and brought it to David.
Now, why did these warriors risk their lives
to break through the Philistine lines?
Was there a military objective
to bring back a really great tasting glass of water?
Of course not. These burly warriors had a soft spot.
They adored their king
and they were ready to lay down their lives just
to do something for him.
Those of you that are parents, would you take a bullet
for your child in a heartbeat?
Why? Because you adore your child. Now, wonderful.
Just multiply that times a thousand
and apply it to king Jesus.
What? Just what if?
What if someday you're captured for your Christian faith
and you find yourself in an orange jumpsuit
with a black sack over your head
and a guy behind you with a big sword?
In your final moments, would you be willing to say,
this is for the king I adore?
Only when you're ready to die for him,
are you actually ready to live for him?
Everything you are, everything you do should be motivated
by a deep adoration for God the Son.
First, you're awakened to Jesus's enthroned glory.
Second, you deeply adore him.
Now, third, you arise
to join him in bringing his kingdom on earth.
Think about the complete gospel when you're redeemed,
you're receiving Christ who died on the cross,
rose from the grave and ascended to glory.
That's the complete gospel.
10 days after the ascension, just 10 days,
Peter preached to Pentecost.
Have you ever noticed his outline?
Let me point you toward Acts two in verse 23.
Peter says this, Jesus, you crucified
and killed by the hands of lawless men.
That's crucifixion.
Verse 32, this Jesus God raised up. That's resurrection.
Verse 33, he Jesus was exalted at the right hand of God.
That's coronation.
When you have conversations with others about Jesus,
I challenge you to use Peter's outline, crucifixion,
resurrection, and coronation.
Such conversations coming from you can be crucial in 2025.
Do you know why? Right now our churches
are filled with church members that would have
to honestly admit, my faith is all about me
and I expect my faith to bring good things
to me and mine their primary prayers sound like this.
Hey Jesus, come down here
and just make everything peachy for me in those in my world.
Does that sound like a Christ awakening to you?
I love my wife more than I can express.
We have been head over heels in love with each other
for 53 years.
I cannot tell you how precious she is,
but she has a challenge.
If you were to discover
that you have an aneurysm on an artery
and that aneurysm is as big as a grape,
that would be serious news for you.
But if a doctor told you now that aneurysm has grown
to be the size of a ping pong ball,
you would start getting your affairs in it in order.
My wife though, has discovered her aneurysm is the
size of an egg.
It is stretched so thin that it's going to break.
And the doctors have told us when it breaks,
the ambulance will not even make it to our house.
So how am I supposed to pray for her?
Only by the power of the Holy Spirit.
This is my primary prayer.
Lord Jesus, would you find creative ways in this
despicable situation?
Would you find ways to draw all attention to yourself?
Would you be glorified in the midst of all
that is taking place?
And then as a secondary prayer, I do pray.
And Lord Jesus, if somehow it could fit in with your plans
and purposes, I would ask with faith that you make my wife.
Well, we were hoping for a house full of kids.
Didn't happen. The doctors finally said,
now we think you will never have children.
And they were almost right. 16 years of waiting.
And finally inexplicably, my wife shows up pregnant.
And the result of that is Clayton,
our only living offspring, he is a big
deal to me.
When he sees me on our campus,
he'll walk halfway across campus
to pick me up and give me a hug.
I love him and he loves Jesus.
When he first started in college,
he was going on multiple mission trips,
international mission trips,
served in South Africa an entire semester, Ethiopia
multiple times, but he got sick.
So he called me up and he said, Hey dad,
I'm not feeling that great.
How about I come home
and y'all just take care of me for the weekend,
wash my clothes, just take care of me
and then I'll be good to go.
And we said, of course, come to our house.
So he came home, crawled in bed
and did not leave that bed for 10 years.
Actually, he was too weak to make it to his bedroom.
On the second floor,
we have a little bitty guest bedroom
right off the dining room.
He stayed in that little guest room for 10
solid years.
All of his buds from my school, all
of his friends getting married, having babies, leaving town
to go start their ministries.
And my son is in bed as sick as he can be.
So when I stand at his door
for 10 years early in the morning,
what am I supposed to pray?
King Jesus, be glorified in all of this.
Make your name even greater on this earth.
Take this entire situation
and cause other people's eyes to be lifted to you.
Secondary prayer. And Jesus, somehow if it could fit,
would you make my son well so he could get on with life?
What about you? How would you pray in a moment like that?
Did you know we have a name for Christianity?
That's all about me. We have a name for it.
Seminarians love, big words. Here's the big word.
We call it moral therapeutic deism.
Now, I mentioned to you earlier,
I'm still out speaking to the teenagers.
Can I, can I walk into an auditorium of teenagers
and say, guess what, you guys have a case
of moral therapeutic deism.
I can't say that, but you know what I can say,
I can say precious teenager.
Is it possible that you have little Jesus in my pocket?
Is it possible that you have little friend,
little buddy Jesus who rides with you through the day?
Maybe you would even say you love him. He's so special.
But because he's little, the nice thing about
that is you can push him way down in your pocket not
to really bother you during the day
until you have a problem or a need.
And then little Jesus can come out and fix it.
In fact, I tell the boys, the upperclassmen, I'll say,
Hey guys, what a deal.
You can take a little Jesus
and push him way down in your tux pocket on prom night
knowing he's not supposed to have anything to say about
what you're gonna do with your girlfriend that night.
He's just a little Jesus.
But two weeks after prom,
what if they tell you your mother's got cancer?
Oh, that's a big deal.
So now little Jesus comes out of my pocket. Jesus.
Jesus, make my mother's cancer all better.
But when the cancer's in remission,
oh great, we're past that.
You go back in my pocket to be mostly
not important in my life till I need you again.
He's just a little Jesus
lest you think that's a teenage issue.
Senior adults can have a little Jesus.
10 year olds can have a little Jesus
parents can have a little
Jesus, mom and dad.
I just wanna say something.
When my Clayton was small,
sometimes I would bring Clayton up on the platform.
When I was trying to teach mom
and dad about how faith moves a generation.
Sometimes I would bring Clayton up on platform
and I would take one end of this pipe
and I would put it against my heart,
and then I would pull Clayton up so
that I could put the other end
of this pipe against his heart
and then I could make a powerful point to parents.
The way faith moves from one generation
to the next generation is through a heart connection.
It is a connection between the hearts.
It's Malachi four, six,
and he will turn the hearts of the parents to the kids
and he will turn the hearts of the kids to the parent.
That is how transmission of faith takes place.
In fact, I have to caution parents, you get distracted
with your life, you lose closeness with your kids.
You parent in a bad way and push them away from you.
You're gonna have this thing pulled out of your chest
so much so that your child's gonna be left with plastic
that's not connected,
and they're gonna give their hearts to their buds
and their buds are gonna put whatever ends up in their
hearts and their hearts.
But the point this morning is this mom
and dad, if you have a small view
of Jesus, if you would truthfully say,
I think mostly I embrace my faith
because it does bring advantages to me.
If it is mostly a self-serving faith,
that's what's gonna go in the pipe.
The research says that the majority
of these young adults
that are deconstructing their faith are deconstructing a
faith that was never that great in the first place.
And often it was a faith that got,
they got from mom and dad.
What I'm trying to say, there are generational issues here
it is one generation becoming smitten with the greatness
of Christ worshiping him as king.
That allows that to move down one and two
and three generations.
Paul absolutely got this.
In fact, all of his letters are full
of the supremacy of Christ.
When you go back and read his letters with this filter,
everything else just makes so much more sense.
All of you could quote Philippians three, eight,
but listen to it in in relationship to supremacy.
Think I consider everything as if,
as if loss compared to
the surpassing greatness of Christ.
I consider everything as if loss compared to
Is that true for you? I'm just asking
you, is it true for you?
Is there a human being on planet earth
that is a bigger deal to you than Jesus?
Is there a human being on earth that is more important
to you than Jesus?
That would be another sermon.
But anything that's more important than Jesus is an idol,
and God has a way of removing idols.
What I'm asking you is have you been so smitten
with the greatness of Christ
that you would say His greatness makes every other part
of me, every other part of my life pale in comparison?
What's your passion in ministry college students?
What's your passion? Do you wanna see people evangelizing
the lo, the loss locally and globally?
Do you long to see people discipling the redeemed
into the image of Christ?
Do you long to see people giving the young a lifetime faith?
Do you want to impact the culture?
Do you want to heal the broken?
Do you want to feed the poor?
All of those things are more likely
and more powerful when you are awakened
to the greatness of Christ.
Hebrews one, two. In these last days,
he triune God.
In these last days He triune.
God has spoken to us by his son.
If triune, God is drawing unusual attention
to the Son in our day, are you gonna join him in doing so?
Here's my closing words to you.
Will you leave these doors in just a few moments committed
to continually awakening to the greatness of Christ?
Will you leave committed to adoring your king regent
with all of your heart, soul, mind, and strength?
Will you leave committed to arising
to join him in bringing his kingdom here on earth,
all for the regal glory of Christ?
All hail king Jesus, I'm gonna ask you to trust.
Just trust me, it's worth it.
Would you take everything out of your hands,
under your, put it under your seat?
Would you just empty your hands? Just trust me.
Please just empty your hands.
And I'm not gonna mess with you, but I want you to do this.
Would you put your hands on your knees?
Put both hands on your knees. Just put 'em right here.
Close your eyes. Close your eyes. All eyes closed.
Now, would you roll your palms up? Just roll your palms up.
What? What? What do you want to receive right now?
What do you want to receive?
So many times in this sermon, I have said, do you need
to be awakened to the greatness of Christ?
November 6th, 2006,
I'm sitting in a Holiday Inn eating a salad, listening
to a man talk about King Jesus.
And my world was turned upside down.
Could an August 24th, 2025 be your day?
Could you someday be lying in hospice
with a smile on your face saying,
Most of my life I was
adoring and living for king Jesus most of my life.
And you know, that all goes back to
an August day in 2025
when I saw the king in a new way.
What I'm really saying to you is,
could scriptural insights this morning by the power
of the Holy Spirit, create a flip in your heart
that really does typify the rest of your time on earth?
It could very well be
that someone right now have has uplifted palms.
But the only thing you could possibly receive this morning
is a brand new first time relationship with Jesus.
And if you don't know him, if you've never met him,
you can tell by by my sermon,
you can tell there are some believers, maybe a lot
of believers who do know him,
but they're really having to catch up in who he actually is.
Person that doesn't know Jesus.
Why don't you just go zero to 60 in one day?
Why don't you just decide if I'm gonna give my heart
and life to Jesus, I'm gonna go all in.
He's gonna be my king from the beginning.
What a wonderful way to begin your Christian experience.
Some of you're trying to figure out your future, some
of you're trying to figure out, where do I go from here?
What do I do? Vocation?
Can you think of anything more exciting to say?
Jesus will give me more details later,
but right now I am declaring to him that my life, my future,
is going to be all drenched with the greatness of Christ.
Even my vocation is gonna be saturated with a desire
to bring his kingdom here on the earth.
I wonder, would any of those topics be
worth a conversation for you?
Would it be worth it for you to say, I'm intrigued
with having a relationship with Christ.
I have no idea how that works.
There're gonna be folk that would love to talk
with you about that in just a moment.
Equally, there are gonna be people that would love to talk
with anyone that's really trying
to pray and think through the future.
Where do I go from here?
Somebody struggling with a massive secret sin
is sucking the life out of you.
Could it be that you falling
before the throne of your king would be the place
that you would find cleansing and grace and forgiveness
and freedom to move forward in your life?
I just want you to know that it's not an accident
that you're here, it's not an accident
that you're hearing this particular teaching this morning,
because I think a bunch of you would say, this is going
to mark a change in my life.
I am going to run hard after my king the rest of my days.
Lord Jesus, I'm praying in that direction. I'm praying.
I'm asking you, Lord Jesus, would you come
and do beautiful things?
Would you honor every conversation
and silent prayer for your name and for your glory?
I pray it. Amen.
Church, let's, uh, yeah,
lemme just remind you that uh, every Sunday we have men
and women at the walls in this room,
just on the edges if you need to pray with somebody.
But I just wanna give, I hate
to say it this way, give permission.
Uh, it shouldn't, you don't need my permission.
But there may be some moments here that you,
you just need to say to Jesus, okay, I'm all in.
And, and a, a symbol of that, a physical posture of
that maybe you're getting on your knees right where you are
or, or even coming up here,
there's nothing super spiritual about this room area up
here, but it may just be like, I need to get on my face
before the Lord and say, Jesus, I'm, I'm all in.
Or gather with some people right around you
and say, Hey, can we just pray, appear
or there where you are, or whatever,
and just say, can we just commit to this together?
Can we say, Jesus, you are the Lord
and king of all things including us.
And maybe that's what God wants to do in this time.
So let's just be willing open-handed towards that.
Again, if you need to pray with somebody,
they're at the edges, uh,
or just gather with your buddies right where you are
and just say, God, we are yours.
So I invite you to stand now if you're able,
or Neil if you're able, or respond as we're able
because the Lord is worthy of it.